وان مر اربعين يوما على الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا الا ان تداعياته لا
تزال مستمره لبل تتفاقم الماسي ايضا
فيضانات مدمره اجتاحت مناطق دفعت الثمن
الاكبر في زلزال وهي ولايه
جنوب تركيا وفقا طبعا لاداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه التي اعلنت ان كميه
الامطار الهاطله في قضاء توت بولايه
اديمان في اخر 24 ساعه بلغت 136 مليمتر في
كل متر مربع واوضحت ان الفيضانات ادت
لمصرع وفقدان عدد من الاشخاص لافته طبعا
الى استمرار عمليات البحث عن المفقودين
اما في شانلي اورفا فقد بلغ معدل هطول
الامطار الى 111
متر لكل متر مربع في اخر 24 ساعه بحسب
طبعا
السلطات هناك كذا واضافت بان الفيضانات
اسفرت عن مصرع سبعه اشخاص وعلى الاقل طبعا
وفقدان شخصين وتم اغلاق المدارس في
الولايه متسببه بدمار منازل وانجراف
للسيارات
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ذلك وما زاد الامر سوءا هي البنى
التحتيه التي دمرها الزلزال في الولايتين
فمجاري الصرف الصحي والمياه تضررت بشكل
كبير مما اثار واثر سلبا على جريان مياه
الامطار وصرفها وكان زلزال مدمر قد ضرب
سوريا وتركيا مما اسفر عن مقتل نحو 55 الف
شخص واجلاء حوالي مليوني شخص الى مراكز
ايواء مؤقته مثل الخيام والحاويات والتي
ما زال بعضها موجودا فيها حتى الساعه
[موسيقى]